I intend to nominate in due time a very
well qualified candidate if we are
following basic precedent then that
nominee will be presented before the
committee's the vote will be taken and
ultimately they'll be confirmed Justice
Kennedy when he was nominated by ronald
reagan in ronald reagan's last year in
office a vote was taken and there are a
whole lot of democrats who i'm sure did
not agree with Justice Kennedy on his
position on a variety of issues but they
did the right thing they confirmed it
and if they voted against him they
certainly didn't mount a filibuster to
block a vote from even coming up this is
the Supreme Court the highest court in
the land it's the one Court where we
would expect elected officials to rise
above day-to-day politics and this will
be the opportunity for senators to do
their job your job doesn't stop until
you're voted up or until your term
expires I intend to do my job between
now and january twentieth of 2017 i
expect them to do their job as well All
Right see who we got here Jeff Mason
Thank You mr. president following up on
that should we interpret your comments
just now that you are likely to choose a
moderate nominee would you know okay
iiiii don't know where you found that
you shouldn't assume anything about the
qualifications that ami other way other
than they're going to be well qualified
all right okay following up would you
consider a recess appointment if your
nominee is not granted a hearing uh I
think that we have more than enough time
to go through regular order regular
processes I intend to nominate somebody
to present them to the American people
to present them to the Senate I expect
them to hold hearings I expect there to
be able